hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to leave or whatever
the hell you pronounce that is I don't
think I'm ever gonna find out and right
now it doesn't matter that's not food
that was a can of paint I can't eat that
that's not gonna help me in any capacity
this is closed the illusion of choice
that I last left off with was nothing
absolutely dick diddly man this hallway
reminds me of something if anyone ever
watched the originally needs your
reaction compilation like the opening
scene from that kind of like this always
I don't know I constantly I know I
constantly go back damn knees at the
Dark Descent but I can't help but make
the comparisons like I draw back from
all the in the install goddammit both of
them it was both an illusion of choice
this is a bunch of [ __ ] but I always
draw back on like my prior experiences
in you know horror and I always look
back on like what I what I've done in
the past and how how that's affected me
okay well I don't think I can go back oh
hey thanks for holding that up for me
you're such a nice guy so like when I
look at horror games I always have to
compare them to what I've done in the
past because that's just where my mind
goes automatically when I play these
games I go back to the good and the bad
experiences that I've had throughout
time and not saying that this is in any
way bad this is actually been very good
and very intriguing and that's an odd
blood stain to have on a couch alrighty
then ooh multiple notes diary of the
affliction we have already encountered
our first setback patient 3 has silently
left our world for the next may he find
peace wherever he may be
doctor Godfried will be performing
necropsy on the assumption that we will
learn more about this illness which has
become known locally as the affliction
the symptoms are unlike anything the
staff is seen some of the patients shows
a surprising degree of apathy almost as
if they have been heavily sedated in
light of this the dosages of sedatives
and painkillers administered to patients
have been reduced as we will still want
them to be able to communicate and
cooperate with us as per usual I will
keep a close eye on the progression of
their symptoms let's see
vard encountered setback is that all the
same one of these apparently so ok so
this is probably the lab area that the
guy was working in
excuse me I can't believe I don't get to
use my hands anymore I just
automatically wrenching things out with
my psychic powers the Karen study of the
patients become quite a nuisance
attempts at washing have been met with
violence and they have become
increasingly uncooperative unwilling to
partake in our examinations horrific
disfigurements are starting to appear
leading me to the conclusion that this
affliction will not be cured by common
medicine it is shown to be progressively
ineffective with treatments this illness
and its symptoms okay so it's hopeless
and then you started experimenting and
worse and worse ways and discovered that
they would be perfect candidates water
ski hey there we go that's a little bit
oh is it a kebab oh is that a kebab
woods multiple kebabs I'm sure they're
not spoiled YUM nom nom nom oh boy uh I
ate him sticking all alright nothing
here I'm gonna come back here nothing
here from you besides the kebabs and a
bunch of unopenable lockers filing
cabinets anyway well this was useless I
made a bit of music and I made a lot of
noise it's pretty much the summary of my
entire existence alright happy hi oh
it's not looking good whenever I go into
a lab area and there's a lot of blood
and dead bodies they even wrap this one
up
they wrap him up probably cuz you were
afraid of the affliction beings Fred in
greatness sadness I've taken notice of
dr. God treats passing it appears that
he has been beaten to death by an
enraged patient his skull cracked open
and his face beaten to a pulp
I still find it rather difficult to
believe this has been the work of a mere
man with bare hands no less they have
informed me that he we will be relocated
to a more suitable working place today
we will have to be cautious because the
patient is still at large and boy howdy
is it a large patient holy [ __ ] that's
probably the guy they're talking about
already the others have left but I will
stay behind I must constraining the
subject has been proven to be difficult
without assistance but the resonators
appear to work I've discovered a safer
way to use the extract in a very potent
restorative concoction as a result of
the new refining process the tincture
has taken on a distinctive red hue which
I find strangely mesmerizing I have
administered this medicine to half the
remaining subjects in hoping that it
will cure them in the affliction and
return them to sanity only time can tell
even though the subjects are showing
signs of improvement their mental state
is still deteriorating I do not feel too
well I think I might have fallen ill
well I was thinking that that guy was
gonna be like going down a spiral
downward spiral of uh of insanity
himself and it seems like he might just
starting to take that but not whew oh I
don't like that oh there's every type of
bad
huama but I'm approaching some bad parts
aren't I
as requested what follows is a list of
all the members and staff and their
aides from the science facility for
reference persons bill peridot polis D
Aaron P Gottfried Kendrick Kovac
Rosenberg Alda nur Miller okay so that's
just a reference of everybody in here
yet that wouldn't open would it yeah but
what dictum
okay is there anything in the book okay
got those moving along huh why how he's
not anywhere is he where is he
Wow hi oh you're are you different Oh
oh good why does he have a red glowy on
his battle
right where is he coming here how much
would hide oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] yeah I've done bad there's nowhere
to hide in here oh [ __ ]
he better not be coming this way I'm
gonna have a jack slap ready for him
box hide me
chair hide me stool you're not chair
you'll never be chair just as duel [ __ ]
okay I think it's fine the novel type of
treatment with Letham appears to be
quite effective the subjects are now
recovering physically as well as
mentally
although scarring and external
defibrillation one might consider this
reasonable after all their bodies been
through they become calm and obedient
but seem to stay apathetic regardless of
external stimulus recently I've noticed
that I seem to be getting splitting
headache whenever I'm near one of the
resonators it might be malfunctioning I
will have to turn some of them off for
further inspection no you're just
becoming inflected with the inflation
okay so oh no god dammit hello oh oh my
gosh I never want to notice that holy
[ __ ] wow I did not notice that at all I
don't know why I just had no thought to
look down holy [ __ ] huh hi well what a
convenient dumping pit for all your
surgical failures oh there's more how
delightful
oh boy I'm so
okay
okay all right okay cool thank you for
that that was cool
glad you did that wonderful time we're
having here for some [ __ ] reason ah
good yes let me check this door first oh
good yes stuff things and food nothing
there but a little bit of food will keep
me going keep me warm and night all
right so this is where the monster is
where the monster was walking through is
he gonna be taking a nap over here
taking a little Betty by a man from the
village barged in begging me to save the
woman in his arms what a gory mess she
was lying there on my table not off me
you see a victim of such cruelty many
parts of her body remained - beyond
recognition she was bearing a child at
the time and if I was to save them both
I had to get it out as soon as possible
in the end I was not able to save what
remained of her left hand I think it is
only reasonable to make full use of this
opportunity that has presented itself to
me after all I had him sign away his
rights to the child so I can continue my
research because I suspect this child
holds secret vitally important to my
scientific endeavors how and why and
what the report of tincture and hood has
proven to be of vital importance it
would have been impossible to keep him
both mother and child alive otherwise
after treating the mothers broken mind
with Letham she has become common
remains to be so although I suspect she
will never return to her former self
after what she has been through well
that's a little bizarre next thing
you're gonna tell me that child is the
me that would make some semblance of
sense given that I've been sent away and
that my father and my real father sent
me away long ago it would make sense
am I gonna take another piss break know
what I'm doing over here
oh never trust the bathrooms you know
who hi buddy
don't mind me don't mind me thank you I
appreciate your sacrifice we're making
sure that that got to me
hello Oh another piss break probably oh
good yeah everyone needs a little
breather every once in a while
hey I just blacked out a second for
pissing there man it was a good one all
right goodbye goodbye
I don't understand I heard that okay all
right so now down this always was where
the monster actually went ah good yes
great actually open yes good oh and it
works what a rare occurrence or was that
well hi oh oh just barely open can't
quite get through though not enough
power Oh
the exit is so tantalizingly close it
must be like a game the developers
playing with us just because they're
like oh here's another exit that you
can't get to ha ha ha ha
ok that's been uh that's been roped off
that's open get out of the way why does
it forces me to do that I can't pick
them up with my own bare hands
she's come in flip one okay does anybody
know what's up with the supply shipments
lately provisions are dwindling and I
hear people complaining about their
orders not being delivered on time
according to the schedule there should
have been at least eight shipments this
month but I've only seen three in the
log and they've all been delayed I don't
know what's going on but if it keeps
happening we're gonna have some major
problems down here
someone should visit management to ask
around to figure out what the hell is
going on and I'll bet that someone is
gonna be me oh gosh
everyone's starving again and then
everyone's turning into horrible
monsters but why do I have to do all the
work this is [ __ ] I hate my life
which is about to end okay anything else
in here other than people just bitching
and moaning about the state of the
kitchen over here huh bitching in the
kitchen with China okay duan boys due to
a negative due to a number of
regrettable incidents management is
henceforth decided that all addictive
activities will be suspended
indefinitely all operational facilities
have been ordered to shut down in all
personnel is hereby required to prepare
for the depart
evacuation will start at 2:00 p.m. this
afternoon and be concluded to 10:00 p.m.
tonight stragglers will be fired with
immediate effect another officer I'd
used if the company asses will not be
tolerated
who wrote that and why and how ok I
guess I'll go this way then see I can't
oh yeah man
my arms are too weak I mean my psychic
powers are great and all but my arms it
just little noodles alright anyway
anybody here
and he sheesh give me ABS any food drink
no okay
down this hello the flooding of the
lower passages makes it difficult to
continue to use the tunnels to lower
laboratories I have had the hatch
installed to dissuade people from
accessing the tunnels until further
notice
beware the hatch is meant to be only be
used in case of emergencies prepare to
get soaked Hey don't promise me a good
time and then not deliver all right here
we go well there's got to be a way to
open the hatch then if it's sealed up
that means a component seal that's
somehow maybe with psycho powers no hmm
that's gotta be a way oh the switch
right below the sign huh that would be
the way that would be right sound like a
voice not necessarily anything else whoo
that's I oh well I just want to leap
down and be ready to attack anything
that came at me come at me bro you suck
hello hidey hidey hidey ho huh
Hidy Hidy Hidy ho please don't come at
me bro okay so that's was that well
that's that's weird
who's playing a harpsichord down here
uh-huh
woogie woogie oh this is where I
prepared to get soaked all right my body
is ready Oh
is there anything down here nah just
decided to take a dip in the best water
for absolutely no reason
okay good okay so there's got to be
something to do with that uh that valve
but I don't know where to put the valve
so if it's not over here oh oh how did I
miss this
what's really how did I miss that nah
man I don't know how this is where I get
soaked okay ah good yes plumbing good I
was down there for half a second man the
new world record oh god no obstacles her
- okay
so where are we now or do I have to pull
these off no I can't even move oh this
way obviously the way without boards in
it Oh that'd be smart okay where am I oh
that don't sound good
oh god that's not good help Oh helm
there we go okay we're fine
alrighty then not too bad only some
minor cases of drowning I mean jeez it
was only a few seconds ah ooh ah it
didn't get any better when the lights
got on still a lot of dead [ __ ] those
things okay seriously just [ __ ] those
things they're only there to be cheap
scares and they get me every goddamn
time [ __ ] bear traps okay I see like
the lever the broken off a wheel I need
the other wheel I need to go get the
wheel and bring it all the way over here
but I don't know how to
yeah because I don't have enough mental
juice oh wait there's another one here
okay I can't pick it up that's so stupid
no not you get over here
yeah you're coming with me
oh it doesn't consume extra juice to
hold it which is weird considering it
seems like I'm is exerting a lot of
force here it'd be good I did it and
what her great Kingdom yeah
this one works really well another one
was a sassy [ __ ] this one is the one I
didn't I just pop it off of that one and
then move it over to the other I don't
know what's happening but it sounds big
okay here we go I don't think that was
enough time so I need to hit it I don't
I need to hit it it'll automatically go
in then I sprint forward only I got dude
here we go la la la la Idid I do
gogogogogogo go [ __ ] go you [ __ ]
bro oh geez
hey yes yes yes great success how can I
please go up the ladder please sir
ma'am what there we go jeez I thought I
was gonna be stuck there get in here
alright what do you get back here you
got ID in here anything food butter I'm
desperate alright nothing there okay
perfume oh Jesus dark who can't see
anything
woo no light blue is just emptiness
okay nothing over there okay alright
unless we got oh it is so dark down here
and quiet too that's never a good sign
mmm Turk in court clerk and coy it and I
gotta go further oh I caught a glimpse
of something I didn't like I got a
glimpse of a bad
well was that okay I'll go down Oh No
huh hi welcome oh it was nothing I
thought I saw something over here I
thought I saw a horrifying figure in the
darkness geez okay everything's fine I
suppose
oh that's a comforting sign hello friend
how you doing hello come on play with me
II okay uh-huh
good yes very good okay so what was the
point of coming in here doesn't seem
like there's a whole lot of anything no
that one's closed and this one's empty
fat a lot of goodness did anybody it did
yeah oh ah smart smart smart smart smart
smart knew there had to be a reason okay
so this goes somewhere okay very bright
okay pull this off [ __ ] [ __ ] with you
[ __ ] good God everywhere why why are
you such sassy sacks of crap ah this
liquid which now emanates with a warm
amber glow is undergone additional
refinement with an electrical flux and
it's starting to show some remarkable
characteristics so far I've been able to
apply this catalyst the machines that
are almost running up dry elevating the
pressure to unexpected levels greatly
increasing their output this catalyst
will prove to be most useful to further
my research thanks dr. Rosenberg I see
you're starting on your descent to
madness maybe maybe not maybe it's just
a good time maybe it's just like my bias
towards people NPCs in these horror
games they're almost always bad with
malicious intent or they eventually end
up that way all right so these are both
locked I think that's where I was before
there's a lot of switches on the walls
but I don't know if I can get to them
there's got to be another way
hmm oh I didn't even see this that's
broken off anyway hello anybody anybody
you think that the lights might work
after a while but apparently no Oh
switch right here of course god damn it
they don't make it easy on me I mean
maybe I'm just an idiot but you know
you'd think they would at least help me
just a little bit okay so this one
opened good great good oh I'll just flip
all these cuz I feel like it hello oh oh
oh well that could've proved disastrous
if there was something worth keeping in
these things hmm Burke oh man yeah and
that's what I wanna one of these big
daddy's over here
what are you ain't doing much where jeez
I'm guessing this is where they kept the
UH the sick patients hello hi friend
how are you doing you holding up okay
okay you have a good one glad your
candles are still burning hello hi oh
man
just empty dirt and oh good god what was
that I dropped down for like half a step
I thought I was falling down all right
never go do that who the hell was that
what the [ __ ] was that
huh run that by me again
[ __ ] you that sounded legitimately like
someone was opening a door over there so
dark
always with the darkness geez what was
the point of this crowd great
broke that up bland I broke that one too
okay so there's no point to being down
here there's nothing down here
what is all this oh why is there a
flashing light over there this place is
just falling apart
falling apart okay what do we got [ __ ]
off oh [ __ ]
oh that does hang whoo-hoo I'm stuck oh
god I thought it was there nothing oh I
thought it was a nothing turns out it
was exactly a thing uh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
dude Oh what am i sorted out oh god oh
god okay all right okay [ __ ] man
where the hell are you doing it oh man
I'm so glad there's not a mechanic
that's like if you stare at him too long
they notice you cuz that was a thing in
amnesia like you stare at him too long
they know you're there oh [ __ ] do they
know oh boy he'll get where to go all
flickering light just be nice to me for
one damn second okay where is he ready
come from pretty go
is that mr. cotton eye Joe
he's around here Oh Nelly whoa Nelly
whoa Nelly I'm gonna walk right into him
whoa Nelly whoa Nelly whoa Nelly whoa
Nelly he's coming back okay he's coming
back
ah okay I think you walked by well [ __ ]
oh my god ah not okay not okay not okay
not okay whoo not okay
okay see obviously something is being
hidden back there okay let's go right in
let's not even wait no I should probably
try to find a note or something that's
probably something kidding around here I
would bet given that this seems to be
like an area that you might want to
leave pretty okay I'm gonna leave pretty
quickly okay all right okay good I don't
like it
we're fine so something back there can i
suck it with my sucking powers oh [ __ ]
oh god damn it where am I supposed to go
[ __ ] it's too dark god damn it is so
dark it's so dark
give me a goddamn light ah there we go
you're going the right way
sure duck Sudak oh hell oh no upon
experimentation with the blue concoction
that I will call let on the rats
cognitive abilities greatly improved in
a short amount of time way beyond their
natural boundaries for now the effect
seems to be temporary but promising
nonetheless I can't I wait to replicate
these results with human subjects that
will commence treatment immediately doc
Andrews in there how do you have any
humans left to experiment on it doesn't
seem like there's a lot of people that
are here and willing to participate okay
goodbye man good thing they put lights
in here thank you very much man
also thank you for the abundance of
crawlspaces around here what do we got
here
heavy caution high pressure let's just
go back why are you doing that what did
I do wrong
I don't know what I did wrong Uriel
maintenance has been postponed time and
time again in this long overdue as usual
but now they tell me the required parts
aren't available and with the shipments
not arriving as scheduled lately the
required overalls are out of question I
sincerely doubt they will arrive in a
respectable amount of time so please
make do with what we have if you really
need to access the upper laboratories
use the override it's that simple PS
just don't forget to set the pressure to
just right half should do okay so half
manual override so half okay there this
something over yeah Wow okay Jesus
so just half I don't really have control
do I need to hold it down no it's just
not doing nothing let on them control
no because that's empty so there's got
to be another one of those things around
here but I don't know how to set them
and this is this isn't something that I
can pull off okay okay so I need I need
some of this yellow guck and then I need
to find a way around here so do I gotta
go back and it doesn't make sense
oh hi ha ha ha ha ha not gonna get me
now this time even though you should
have gotten me before I think they just
place that a little more forgiving me
either way I think I'm I'm out of time
for this episode so I'll figure this out
in the next one before I actually
started I'll have this figured out so
you don't have to wait on me so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next bye
bye is such a bizarre thing I actually
don't think I'd mind sweating damn I
could make living a flip it open parties
all your damn puzzle sex is the GU are
you sexy